hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute stehen wir in einer person
küche vor für bücher und zwar trat im
globus wiesental und da gibt's jetzt
seit neuestem eine küche in der man zwar
für kurse geben kann ohne strand kochen
und backen kann und heute dem oliver
folgen der oliver arbeitet eben topfit
studio und du bist ernährungsberater
genau und wie er zwei kann man zusammen
geschlossen und zwar haben heute einen
kurs gemacht oder maßen gerade noch mit
noch mittendrin gelungen ihre gerade
noch hinter uns fleißig gekocht und
gebacken und zwar macht ihr immer topfit
studie jack russel genau wie am prozent
abnehmen kurs gate fünf wochen das ganze
ding eines dem training einfach auch in
kombination mit ernährung zu wägen sie
heute hier genau und ist topfit studio
ist halt auch direkt neben dem globus
als events vielleicht noch nicht kennt
kann da noch vorbeifahren und dafür man
in so einem kurs zusammen und geht es
einfach um gesunde ernährung bewusste
ernährung und das heute ist auch das
erste mal in der küche und auch mein
erster kurs hier und der oliver aber
freuen schon mit den ganzen teilnehmern
des wahren islam jetzt aber sind
insgesamt 20 schritt war schon im
globus-markt wasserträger grad genau
habe einfach diese tour durch den globus
gemacht ein opposition in diese richtung
lebensmittelkunde warenkunde was gibt es
auch was dort macht beim einkauf einfach
unterschied zwischen einzelnen
lebensmittel sachen einfach
richtig genial und dann sind sie einfach
hierher gekommen und ich habe dann schon
rezepte gerichtet das frühstück
mittagessen abendessen und natürlich für
dsl und direkt mitten drin haben immer
zwei teilnehmer eine rezept karte
bekommen und haben dann zubereitet und
ich glaube wir gehen jetzt einfach noch
mal nach hinten zeigt euch ein bisschen
lassen auch und später über essen und
damit aufgeräumt und dann ist auch schon
vorbei also kommt einfach mit
also jetzt beim essen die menüs oder die
rezepte von füße kam jetzt schon
gegessen
jetzt ist gerade das mittagessen dran da
gab es nur eine auswahl und vergabe
hähnchen gefüllt mit getrockneten
tomaten und anrufen gemüse mit dazu und
jetzt sind alle krater fleißig um essen
und am besten mache ich jetzt eine
kleine kurze feedbackrunde
und weil du kannst nichts zu essen hat
würde ich dich am besten fragen wie war
es für dich wunder wunder wunderschön
erzählt
das war eine der schönsten tage in
meinem leben ist schön
es hat richtig spaß gemacht das war
wirklich informativ ist auch am anfang
als er dann durch den globus geht auf
und sendet über die erste lebensmittel
geräte richtig interessant jetzt auch
das hat spaß gemacht mit dem kochen
danke ich auch schon verzicht webers
kritik
ich war richtig schön unfall beim
frühstück gefrühstückt haben das hat
schon was haltet ihr zubereitet dem
flattermann kannst du gut sein wie war
es für dich
ich fand es hat richtig viel spaß macht
und zwar echt lecker freut euch bestimmt
schon aufs abendessen oder wie war es
für dich sehr schön sehr viel spaß
gemacht und dessen mama zu hause
nachkochen auf jeden fall was
alltagstauglich genau auf jeden fall
oder war sehr gut weil es bis jetzt
schön ich glaube jetzt alles ziemlich
fertig gegessen jetzt gibt es gleich das
abendessen und damit man das dessert und
da machen wir gleich eine kleine
fragerunde
jetzt darf ich dich bestimmt kurz fragen
wie das abendessen hatte man ja die
haben wir gemacht und die wand sehr gut
aber vor allem dass honig senf war unser
favorit richtige antwort war es bei dir
gar kein cola salat hersteller probiert
wie war es mal wirklich besser
betrachten
ja bei dir auch die auto also man kann
schon noch mal essen haben mein
lieblingsland besser als ich gedacht
dass ihr probiert haben ich bin auf der
fan von honig senf dressing rucola salat
schmeckt nämlich auch kunst sehr gut
zubereitet
also ich muss sagen mein favorit war
ehrlich gesagt auch dass honig senf
dressing marco kolossal ich glaube alle
haben aufgegessen
die süßen dinge am ende also das beste
kommt zum schluss würde ich sagen was er
heute eigentlich so mein erster und
backkurs kann man nicht vergleichen mit
den unterrichtsstunden im htg unterricht
das ist schon ein bisschen was anderes
für mich war es wirklich so schön ich
mag auch gleich noch eine feedbackrunde
wie die teilnehmer des verwandten und
ich hatte wirklich sehr viel spaß und
freude daran
es ist auch richtig schön sich hiermit
an unterhalten zu können und die gruppen
größere ideal also 20 leute ich kein
game mehr dürfen es auch nicht sein
damit etwas ungemütlich aber so konnte
ich einfach mal bei jedem mit dabei
sitzen und ich mit allen unterhalten und
mal schauen ob es in zukunft auch
malkurse geben wird ich fand auf jeden
fall toll und werden jetzt auch gleich
direkt richtung deshalb begeben und
einfach mal alles ausprobieren also wie
gefragt haben wir einfach so klassische
desserts wie tiramisu so ein bisschen
freier gemacht mit joghurt oder
mascarpone
apple crumble habe ich die klassischen
sträußen weggelassen und müsse
stattdessen verwendet einfach die
besseren fette mit drin zu haben und
heute abend bin ich natürlich ziemlich
chaotin der tag war heute wirklich sehr
lange und ich hoffe dass euch das video
gefallen hat und wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß am kochen und backen versieht
gefährt und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal bis dahin tschüss